book so I actually think when most when  these men cheat you know they don't  cheat because they want to cheat right  I'm not taking the responsibility away  from them but men are weak and women  know how women are  some women can be so what's the word  unoffensive like they so forward didn't  it and when you put a man that's got  these status got this Cloud called these  riches the types of women that go up to  him like you know men yeah like you know  and then some you know used to always  get caught like Ashley Cole and John  Terry you will see the woman that would  cheat with and you'll be like bruh you  just wouldn't understand it man that's  the worst day when you realize you have  to worry about ugly girls too oh my God  ugly ugly fat girls that can cook you  need to worry about these women